welcome back to the witch yes we're here
in New York City and I turn to my right
some someone I have not seen in quite
some time he is the host of get up on
ESPN every single morning from 8 a.m. to
10 a.m. a longtime host of Mike and Mike
on the radio and a Sports Center man
through and through good to see you Mike
Greenberg well it's great to see you as
well I was just talking to TJ back there
doing social and I told him that when I
got to ESPN and we started working
together I heard you say I think you did
get hired just before I did it was 23
years ago not crazy so how is that we
must have been like in fourth grade I
don't know that pretty much we were we
were that just young pups I think
however you had to go on ESPNEWS before
you started that's how I started so when
you were I was the last one to not have
to do that you were the first one to
have to do this i was hired as part of
that group of people that we all came in
together to start that which is sort of
like being in a fraternity pledge class
we also have that in common so it was
myself chasing Jackson Ian page Dave
Feldman Chuck our find Michael Kim Dave
reps and the only one who was still at
ESPN besides me as Jon Butchie grass and
we all started together we played golf
every single day and we anchored until
3:00 in the morning and they were very
that I think kindly very few people
watering so there was very little
pressure on it I still have have yet to
find somebody in our profession better
at golf than John Boudreau he's very
good I mean very good does he really oh
yeah I think he gives strokes to the
course right he's very good he's
remarkably good dragged in a
conversation but I took Taylor Twellman
out to play golf with me recently having
no idea right that he is a scratch and
that his grandfather was on tour Taylor
Twellman is a ridiculously good golf
right but I'm talking about anchors
right anchor men or women the best I've
ever seen at golf is bucho gross and
couldn't have been nicer cuz I was
spraying the ball all over the place and
he was just brilliant and kept wanting
to play golf or allowing me to play golf
with him pretty much
what a good guy he's a great guy like
you and Buchi Ross are the only ones
from that class right and we were we
were when they first formed ESPNEWS they
made the two of us John and I an anchor
team worked together for a month every
day and they decided we were too goofy
and I have literally not done a show
with him now in 23 years I think one
night again bear in mind we were
literally anchoring a broadcast that no
one was watching right so we did we we
had different nights we tried to work
Barry Manilow lyrics into our like on a
given night we might do that like you
and Stuart we're doing all these really
cool catchphrases and this was like the
closest I could get I was like I'm gonna
see if I can get she came and she gave
without taking yes into this summer and
how'd that work terribly I think they
broke us apart and I've literally not
worked with him I've worked with you
more recently than worked with John Ross
Wow damn I remember we were talking
about why were we talking about ESPN
news the other day but we were because
Bill Peto kept coming off because he
would call it the Box eysan eysan I'm in
the Box tonight to put me in the box
because again it was the studio that was
adjacent or right next to the the
newsroom
yeah eysan in the box in the box then
tomorrow I'm oh ffs off watch out for
the black ice going home tonight on road
for eyes and it's cold out there yeah
we've got a situation situation oh my
developing situation that is you know I
I've thought a lot when I you were nice
enough to invite me to come down here I
started thinking a lot about those days
yes and look I mean everything has
changed in the world since then but when
I got to ESPN people asked me about you
know working there all the time when I
got to ESPN the early evening
SportsCenter anchor team was a
combination of Bob Lee Charley Steinem
and Robin Roberts the 11 o'clock was
Keith and Dan and the overnight show was
you and Stuart I mean you know that's
like iconic that to me was iconic an
iconic time and I look I still look back
on that so fondly like just to get there
and to be a little part of that I
remember getting hired and it was when
they were doing construction on the
campus so we were in those little
trailers yes and they just put me at a
desk and Keith Olbermann for his sitting
like right
and I'm thinking like this guy is the
greatest sportscaster maybe that ever
lived and he's to me he was a
larger-than-life famous figure oh yeah
and he's working out of a trailer like
at a little tiny desk opposite mine
poking a pipe that's what it was he had
the pipe and the height and everything
else yeah I was I mean those are
one-handed way yeah and all that caps
I've never seen him but he types with
one hand yeah I would use the other hand
just hit the spacebar when I've never
seen it by anybody else oh yeah that
happened Wow it was great but so did you
were you there when Kilbourne was there
at the very killed we'll have to right
before I had I never met him I did I did
a few with him before he left I've told
this story that we went on to dinner one
night as a - is it the feel-good Edition
that I sat next to him because I guess
Hebert was off that night or something
and there's a feel-good Edition he says
hey spark let's go to dinner
so we hop in his car and he takes me to
the Kenny Rogers rolling roaster
drive-through in southern tenure by the
neighboring Southington Connecticut and
as we're going through the drive-thru
tells me that his contracts coming up
again I'm 26 fresh out of Redding
California maybe maybe a dozen sports
centers into my career and he starts
telling me about another opportunity
that he has winds up describing to me
the daily show yeah and asks me what I
think he should do as he reaches out to
grab the bag of food that he bought for
me grabbing my chicken the evening and I
remember just saying I don't know Craig
you should just follow your gut follow
your dream I'm with Craig Kilborn
through it through a drive-through and
have you seen his Instagram account
lately no people talk about it a lot
I've seen a little bit of it but no I
know people make a very big deal of he's
back he's back oh God oh it's epic it's
at the martinis in the Winkies yes and
there are dissolves and we are
dissolving he dissolves he just
dissolves a lot of dissolved he'll call
for the dissolve
I have to check this out I haven't seen
it it is it is uh I will say nothing
describes working at ESPN in the 90s
quite like dinner at 3:00 in the morning
at the Kenny Rogers Drive that's it that
that was that was like that was the that
was like oak cuisine in our lives at
that time that was as good as it could
possibly get now look at you man working
in New York City in Manhattan that was
my dream
that was my dream yeah which is and that
dream went so well I I went to the time
slice off my windshield on January with
a credit card
my greenberg here on the Rich Eisen show
alright you came out of the green room
listening to our poll question which is
which breeder off one more time Brock
Bernie yeah yeah which a 20-18 division
winner least likely to repeat bears
Cowboys Ravens Texans I would say Ravens
is my pick out of those although I would
put a caveat I think and I heard you
talking about Zeek Elliot and I saw you
trying to do the it was nothing it
didn't it didn't go over but I think
however big a deal shows like yours and
mine have made of the Zeek Elliot thing
I believe we are under selling its
significance because I genuinely believe
that with Ezekiel Elliott the Cowboys
are a Superbowl favorite and without him
I don't think they'll make the playoffs
so I think he's literally that important
to player he is as important to that
team as practically any quarterback is
to their team that said I believe he
will wind up there and so I think
they'll win that division
I think the Bears are gonna win their
division we had some guys on my show
this morning all picking Minnesota I was
surprised I liked the Bears a lot the
Texans
I would have said Indianapolis until
Saturday morning I would have said
Indianapolis by the time we went to
sleep Saturday night I no longer thought
so so I'd say the Ravens because I think
both Pittsburgh and Cleveland will be
better than them you know the one that I
would choose is the Texans I am
genuinely concerned of their offensive
line that running game I know Duke
Johnson is there and and I just you know
and that he did have quality campaigns
as a collegiate of being a bell cow in a
way I need to see what what's going on
there and and I think Brissette can
still win this division I really do I
think
there they're equipped Dallas I totally
agree with you about with Ezekiel
Elliott I totally agree with you
the Vikings optimist them when you hear
people talk up the Vikings the one
person here is Gary Kubiak is there now
yeah
and that Dalvin cook ran away from the
entire Arizona defense the other day and
that you put those two things together
that Cousins is gonna have somebody in
Kubiak that is actually they're gonna
put this offense together in a way that
Zimmer's defense will back it up and off
they go and win that division that's the
that's the the bright sunny aspect I am
a big table punter for the Ravens though
I have to disagree with you so what
exactly do you think Lamar Jackson is
going to be everything I love him and I
think this whole business of him not
being able to throw the football as much
I think is an absolute misnomer I know
what he looked like last year he looked
like a rookie coming into the NFL in the
middle of a season where an offense was
completely retooled just for him and he
almost went every single game that he
played in the regular season and they
have this year Mark Ingram to go with
that running game and Hollywood Brown
I'm keen to see what he looks like
taking the top of the defense off I
think Lamar Jackson is gonna run the
ball even more I think they're gonna
really maybe do some crazy Taysom Hill
stuff with tres McSorely I think they're
gonna be far more imaginative than
anybody's gonna give him credit for and
then on top of it do not discount Earl
Thomas go in there
that's a Hall of Famer right there man
with a big chip on his shoulder flipping
birds at his former coach you know all
that stuff I think he's the Ravens fans
are gonna love him I'm very high on the
ratings as you can tell yeah and look I
I love their coach and I wouldn't
discount any of those possibilities
right but I am buying in on Cleveland
and I know there's sort of a split
opinion on whether that's just going to
be a colossal disaster or they're gonna
really catch lightning in a bottle
putting all these you know personalities
together and bringing in so many
different places I think it's gonna work
and maybe that's wishful thinking I just
think it would be so fascinating to see
that team be good and I think the
Steelers are going to be better for
getting rid of Antonio Brown and that's
who I put into the playoffs as a Wow
car team so no Costa Texans I'm not
ready to throw out I need to see what
the Chargers look like without Melvin
Gordon and Derwin James is out that's
significant
I'm not ready to put the charges back in
yet let's put it that way so uh uh you
can't I I wouldn't be surprised if three
teams make it from the from the AFC
North what it what do you think about
the Jets so I can't believe it took us
this long how long an example let me
just I'll answer your question this way
yes we were talking about our kids
backstage we were saying hello and I
don't think that they're too upset about
it they're 18 and 16 so they're mature
enough to understand the importance of
these things I've renamed my son Sam and
my daughter darling I've been waiting
for this all of my life I'm so than you
are but I'm not old enough to remember
January 12th 1969 I was alive January 12
1969 yes but that's only they only know
that because I've been told so okay so
I've not seen it I've lived through
Richard Todd I've lived through ken
O'Brien I've lived through the dalliance
as with Boomer Esiason and Vinny
Testaverde and Glen Foley and Niall
O'Donnell and then into Chad which was I
was so hopeful and then the injuries
sort of tada Lucas and Ray Lucas and and
and well I mean if you want to get all
the way into Ricky Myra and all the eyes
that happens right but then ultimately
Sanchez which was another flirtation and
but now we've got it now for the first
time in my lifetime that the Jets have a
quarterback I genuinely believe is going
to be a star a major star and I think
while they took a circuitous route the
firing the timing of the firing of the
general manager did not sit well with me
but they took her security route to get
there but I like where they are I like
the coach I like the defensive
coordinator
I like the acquisitions we haven't even
seen levy on bail yet and I like the new
general manager for whatever that's
worth that's more big picture not a
small right I think the Jets are going
to be much improved and I think they
have a chance to make the playoffs I do
the problem is the the early schedule is
so tough they could get buried if
they're three and four the Jets are
gonna make the playoffs they say at
Buffalo at home first they should win
that one they've got the Monday nighter
against Cleveland which I can't wait for
yeah that's a huge then they've got
week three they take on the Patriots
right they take on in week seven as well
and when you want to take on New England
I want to take him on early in the
season
whenever the new folks that are brought
into New England haven't figured out
just do your job right you know
sometimes they can't figure that out the
offense sometimes takes a few weeks to
get that's why I kind of like the way
that that's worked out for the Jets
so maybe possibility was to do love
these Buffalo and win one more you know
what we are I think in the media the
most jet shiest people that are out
there right I'm trying to think if there
are any other ones national media you
know there are no closeted Jets fans
there are only cause Latin jazz fans we
are that which means you know you gotta
you got a reserve you got a in that Mets
we got Pete Alonzo on later on you gotta
believe with Mets with the Jets you got
a reserve you got a reserve and I I am
pleased to see levy on bail easily the
most talented skilled player they've had
since Curtis Martin you can't even make
any other bones about it
I mean he's from as tremendous as they
come individually talented he may be the
most individually talented player the
Jets have ever had
Le'Veon Bell rushes for more yards in a
game that OJ Simpson and catches more
passes in a game than Michael Irvin or
Chris Carter he has a Hall of Fame
runner and receiver and he's on the Jets
which is to be allowed to happen I'm
saying got a reserve quick story do I
have time for sure and I'm a little kid
Howard Cosell was my idol and I know
they're a much mine yours as well I
remember the first time through the 70s
again I'm two years older than you the
Jets never made the halftime highlights
all undeniable cuz they were so bad
correct so then that first year 81 they
make that they make that run to the
playoffs the year they were ten five and
one and Howard Cosell like halftime of a
game does a jet highlight and I went
running from my room screaming to my
father you're not gonna believe this
Howard Cosell knows who the Jets are
right like that seemed impossible to
believe the Jets were people only we
knew only we knew Clark games America
didn't know Clark games and reams
MacNeil by the time we got freedom Akhil
we were good
exactly so so so that that's been the
lot in life of the jet fan I think this
is our time I think our time is actually
coming my brother and I used to complain
to each other that Cosell did not put
the jets in the Monday Night Football
halftime highlights again see I
considered a figure than they judged it
was the opposite I see that's the
difference between you and me is that
you took issue with him yes I thought
less of myself for being a jet my team
isn't even good enough for Howard Cosell
to know who they know or like where
should be good enough why the hell are
we not on on the halftime highlights
that's the way we viewed it in the eyes
and we weren't good enough I mean
unfortunately oiler alert correct you're
right
tell me about get up sir get up is great
I'm having a wonderful time doing the
new show and we're here in New York yeah
when we did the very brief TV insert I
don't mean to bring you back to this but
I wanted to do this okay you are now one
of my five favorite Staten Islanders
okay we're gonna guess who the other
four okay here we are
Alyssa Milano no and all the list even
Sugano okay I know tank Lao huh ricky
schroder no and they are all the four of
them I'm going to give you a give away
hint okay before them are best friends
and host a television show all together
oh they're all the Impractical do
practical jokers please tell me you like
those guys I do and as a consequence I
have fallen in love with Staten Island
just watching through them yes their
extraordinary pride in Staten Island has
made me proud to have grown up
relatively near that so it's me and the
Impractical Sal Murr Joe Alyssa Milano's
didn't even break crack the top see I
did Google who else is from Stanton I
lied iddin no Ricky Schroder man yeah I
cried when I saw the champ circa 1970 is
it correct so I should make that guy as
the wu-tang clan you're getting knock
further and further down is what's
happening I understand that whatever
you've always Holland Joe season
Saturday live now that's right that's
right he did a movie called Staten
Island I remember that just right across
the river right here Robin closed the
harbor
right across the harbor um 8 a.m. to 10
a.m.
tell jaylen I said huh I will he is very
excited are you very excited for Juwan
Howard victim yeah
Jalen is out of his mind I'm very
crestfallen that that beeline left but
if that leads to JaJuan coming back and
bringing some of that fab 5 magic I like
it
is this the year when I could have said
that's that's been every year yeah but
but there's no admirer there's no more
quarterback at Ohio State they got a
transfer oh gosh every single year you
say there's no more quarterback at Ohio
State there is one you know I mean the
Year JT Barrett when it went out injured
in the big house I'm like we got this
and that's when Dwayne Haskins came home
yeah and now you know we all know what
he's doing I have high hopes for it you
got a reserve that's with me and Mike
it's funny like every year I have an at
the end of the year I have one of those
moments where man
you know I love my school just wasn't
our year and I got a good job I got a
good life I love my wife my kids are
great you know my parents are healthy
and I go through this whole mental
rigmarole to get over the loss and I'm
like why can't I just be like an Alabama
fan and a Clemson fan you sit back and
you watch your team win a damn thing off
you know I've always thought you and I
were so similar and now I realize we're
so different I sit and make a mental
checklist of all the things in my life
that are terrible like that's the
different you sit here and you think
about all the wonderful I would be the
same geographic area and of the same
ethnic persuasion if you know what's
true how did you get to be an optimist I
think what it all comes down we just
blame our parents well know that but
that only takes you so far I'm 52 years
old I have so many problems no two
people can be responsible for them alone
at ESPN greenie watch get up every day
8:00 a.m. to 10:00 a.m. this has been a
blast man thank you it is great to see
you congratulations on everything my
best I am right back to you
right back at you that's my Greenberg
right here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app